so actually you're 16 as well so do you
have your driver's license yeah you know
I actually so I got my permit like
immediately once I could so in
California you can get it when you're 15
and a half got it right away I was so
prepared for it I was gonna get my
license when I was 16 but then I was out
on tour so I was like I will wait till
I'm 16 and half when I'm back from tour
turns out it takes like three months in
advance you have to book your
appointment at the DMV I had no idea
about
that's not normal expired yes so now I
had to renew my permit which I actually
did this morning I was at the DMV at
like 8:00 a.m. oh wow it was really fun
the people at the people at the DMV they
had kids and they recognized me so they
took me like into the back of the DMV
into like their private office and they
all wanted pictures like yeah so can you
help me get my license that you touch
people like that that their kids are
inspired by you that's pretty cool you
know it's actually really cool to me
when parents know because a lot of
obviously kids watch my videos so the
kids are gonna know who I am
but when the parent knows what the kid
watches and the parent can recognize Who
I am like that means that they're
invested and that they watch it together
like I love it when parents come up it's
just because that means it's like a
thing they do together then brings
family together that's really cool I
love your spirit I love your vibe so but
what I heard that you also have a car
with your face on it which I really want
to see right two of them that's my test
all I have that's the test you just rock
that Tesla out and that you're going
incognito is not really a thing
Nickelodeon and the first one of the
first meetings that I had in the
collodion the girl who runs consumer
products over there she was like you
know you don't have to show up like that
to it and I showed up like this and she
was and I was like yeah this is this
this is what I do I was like this is me
I'm not dressing up like anything and so
I don't you just thought you that was
your character she thought it was like a
character and every everybody thinks
that Jojo is some sort of character but
uh
it's obsessive rain that's her favorite
color is rainbow like honey that's like
a lot of colors but okay cool
so wait do you have any like pre-show
rituals you have to do oh you know I
actually I don't I do I do I do this is
complicated I'll tell you something
there is something we're performers we
all do shows there's something that the
three of us do that every performer does
before every single show but no one will
ever speak of it P know you're close by
oh yeah because if you don't want to
Germany I actually I am in my venue my
show is at 7 o'clock it's an earlier
show because it's for kids but I'm in my
venue no later than 10:00 a.m. and I
actually I do my own hair and makeup Wow
I do all my boy dancers hair I get i
colored their hair every single day yeah
I do that every single day Wow it's
really fun there's my dancers with their
colored hair is that was from our first
show actually that's so fun I just sound
check every single day obviously I some
days we play Monopoly you're on oh I was
a Scrabble girl that's what I jumped for
it's great my best friend played
Scrabble but we played it where we could
only make up words well that I would not
believe that version so fun I am like so
annoyingly like rigid about rules oh I
can never play Scrabble with you jo-jo
that fit so is there anything you have
to do before you go onstage my pre-show
rituals nothing like that I usually you
know I usually go do my meet and greet
we do a little VIP show before the show
and a show before a show yeah that's
like a little VIP thing you play a few
songs and and and then I go in the
dressing room with my band and just
crank some music and have a couple
drinks I don't judge so but that's kind
of that you know that's kind of our
thing just kind of get loose get ready
for the show
doesn't even ever played Monopoly before
shelves hey God I don't know how you
play Monopoly for show cuz it takes
seven hours that's the joy of hours are
a good kiss and out long enough to do
that before show I'm a boy sand board
games what the hell is wrong with you oh
sorry don't say that don't like board
games I love more game I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this